>> CNN HAS LEARNED OF THE FIVE
OFFICERS WHO WERE INDICTED, ONLY
ONE REMAINS IN JAIL.
THE OTHER FOUR WERE RELEASED ON
BOND.
DESMOND MILLS JR. IS ONE OF
THOSE FOUR OFFICERS POSTING HIS
$250,000 BOND LAST NIGHT AND HE
IS BACK HOME NOW WITH HIS
FAMILY.
SO SPEAKING OF THAT OFFICER, I'M
JOINED NOW BY THE ATTORNEY FOR
DESMOND MILLS JR., BLAKE BALLEN.
BLAKE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE POLICE CHIEF IN AN INTERVIEW
JUST A SHORT WHILE AGO SAID THAT
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE TO
SUBSTANTIATE THE CLAIM OF
RECKLESS DRIVING.
THEY HAVEN'T FOUND ANY EVIDENCE
IN VIDEO OR OTHERWISE.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> THAT PROOF IS IN THE PUGD.
.
I NEED TO SEE IT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE VIDEO WE'RE
ALL WAITING TO SEE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING ABOUT
THE STOP FROM A DEFENSE
STANDPOINT.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING STAGES OF
THINGS AND WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT WHAT EVI
THEY HAVE.
>> THE OFFICERS HAD A DUTY OF
CARE, IT WAS SAID BY THE POLICE
CHIEF THAT THEY DID NOT FOLLOW
THE MEMPHIS POLICE DEPARTMENT'S
GUIDELINES FOR DUTY OF CARE,
THIS HE DID NOT RENDER CARE,
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS ALSO THE
KIDNAPPING CHARGE AS WELL.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> WELL, SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
THAT KIDNAPPING CHARGE, OF
COURSE, HAVING NOT SEEN THIS
VIDEO, IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
TALK ABOUT THE FACTS, BUT TO SAY
THAT, YOU KNOW, AN OFFICER WHO
CROSSES A LINE OR DOES SOMETHING
ILLEGAL IN DETAINING SOMEBODY
HAS COMMITTED AN AGGRAVATED
KIDNAPPING IS A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT TO SET.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> WELL, EVERY TIME A FOURTH
AMENDMENT VIOLATION OCCURS,
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY CLAIMS THEY
HAVE BEEN WRONGFULLY ARRESTED BY
A POLICE OFFICER, WHETHER AN
EGREGIOUS VIOLATION OR A SLIGHT
ONE, ARE OFFICERS NOW LOOKING AT
BEING CHARGED WITH AN A, FELONY,
LOOKING UP TO 25 YEARS IN JAIL.
IT WILL MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
OFFICERS TO DO THEIR JOBS.
>> THERE IS THE ATTEMPTED MURDER
CHARGE DR OR THE MURDER CHARGE,
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER CHARGE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT IS AN
OVERCHARGE AND DIFFICULT TO
PROVE?
WHY?
>> THAT REQUIRES THAT THEY PROVE
THAT MR. MILLS ACTED WITH A
REASONABLE DEGREE OF CERTAINTY
WITH REGARD TO HIS ACTIONS.
THAT HIS ACTIONS WERE CERTAIN TO
CAUSE DEATH, AND THAT'S JUST
SIMPLY NOT THE CASE.
WHEN THIS VIDEO COMES OUT I
EXPECT THAT MR. MILLS WILL NOT
BE DELIVERING BLOWS THAT CAUSED
DEATH.
>> WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> BECAUSE I'VE SAT DOWN WITH
MR. MILLS, I'VE LOOKED HIM IN
THE EYE, I KNOW THE KIND OF
PERSON HE IS.
I HAVE TALKED WITH OTHER PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SEEN THE VIDEO AND I
JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT MR.
MILLS IS CAPABLE OF COMMITTING
THAT ACT.
>> WHAT DID HE TELL YOU ABOUT
THE CONFRONTATION?
>> I CANNOT TELL YOU WHAT MY
CLIENT HAS TOLD ME.
>> CAN YOU GIVE US AN INDICATION
OF -- YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU
DON'T BELIEVE THAT HE DELIVERED
BLOWS SO OBVIOUSLY IN YOUR
CONVERSATIONS HE TOLD YOU I DID
NOT DELIVER BLOWS?
>> HE IS NOT THE ONLY PERSON I
HAVE TALKED TO, DON.
>> OKAY.
YOU'VE TALKED TO OTHERS AND WHAT
DID THEY SAY?
>> I'VE TALKED TO OTHERS AND THE
LEVELS OF CULPABILITY AMONGST
THESE FIVE OFFICERS ARE
DIFFERENT AND I EXPECT THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IN THIS
VIDEO THAT MY CLIENT, DESMOND
MILLS, IS NOT, IN FACT, GUILTY
OF THE CRIMES HE HAS BEEN
CHARGED WITH.
>> THEN WHY WOULDN'T HE RENDER
AID IF THERE WERE OTHER PEOPLE
WHO WERE CULPABLE?
GO ON.
SORRY.
>> THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YESTERDAY,
WHETHER MR. MILLS WAS INJURED,
THERE'S PEPPER SPRAY FLYING IN
THE AIR.
WHAT HE WAS DOING WHILE OTHERS
WERE ACTING IN AN UNLAWFUL WAY,
UNTIL I SEE THAT VIDEO I CAN'T
SAY.
>> SPEAKING TO THE FATHER OF
TYRE NICHOLS, HE SAID THERE'S
VIDEOTAPE, THE TAPE SHOWS THAT
TYRE WAS PROPPED UP AGAINST A
WALL, HANDCUFFED, THAT HE IS
SLUMPED OVER, THE OFFICERS LIFT
HIM BACK UP AND SAYS, YOU KNOW,
SOME EXPLETIVES ABOUT SIT UP OR
GET UP.
IF HE'S SITTING THERE, WHY
OFFICERS COULDN'T JUST TRY TO
GET HIM TO A HOSPITAL TO GET AID
TO HIM, TO THE PARAMEDICS?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY OF THIS.
WHEN I DO I CAN COMMENT ON IT.
FOR NOW I JUST -- I CANNOT
ANSWER THAT WITHOUT HAVING SEEN
THIS VIDEO.
>> THE REASON THAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
CULPABILITY IS BECAUSE OF THE
AMOUNT OF BAIL, IS THAT WHAT YOU
BELIEVE?
>> THAT'S PART OF IT.
PART OF IT IS JUST MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH MY CLIENT, WITH
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, WITH THE
U.S. ATTORNEY.
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN IN CONSTANT
CONTACT WITH THE PROSECUTORS
HERE.
WHILE I HAVEN'T SEEN THE VIDEO I
KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE AND I EXPECT
THERE'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF ACTION HERE AND SO I
CAUTION EVERYONE TO LOOK AT THIS
WITH AN OPEN MIND AND TO TREAT
EACH OF THESE OFFICERS AS
INDIVIDUALS.
>> AS YOU KNOW UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO HAS DIED AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE -- EVERYONE
INVOLVED, MOST PEOPLE INVOLVED
SAYING, LISTEN, THE VIDEOTAPE IS
DAMNING, IT'S GOING TO BE HARD
TO GET SOME LEVEL OF SYMPATHY OR
EMPATHY FOR YOUR CLIENT.
YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT YOU
HAVE SPOKEN TO HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS ABOUT THE HISTORY AND
WHO OFFICER MILLS IS AS A PERSON
AND WAS AS AN OFFICER.
>> LET ME SAY THIS FIRST, THAT
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE NICHOLS
FAMILY.
AS A DEFENSE LAWYER THIS IS AN
INTERESTING CASE FOR ME.
I HAVE DEDICATED MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE TO FIGHTING AGAINST
INJUSTICE IN THE SYSTEM, TO
FIGHTING AGAINST A SYSTEM WHERE
THERE'S SYSTEMIC RACISM FOR
CENTURIES AND TO NOW FIND MYSELF
REPRESENTING SOMEBODY WHO IS A
PART OF THAT SYSTEM IS AN
INTERESTING POSITION TO BE IN,
BUT I WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT JUST BECAUSE MR. MILLS WAS
A PART OF THAT SYSTEM DOESN'T
MEAN THAT HE CAN'T ALSO BE A
VICTIM OF IT.
AND SO IT'S MY JOB TO PROTECT
HIM AND TO PROTECT HIS RIGHTS,
AND I'M DOING THAT NOT ONLY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN THE SYSTEM,
BUT BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN MR.
MILLS.
I HAVE TALKED TO HIS FAMILY,
I'VE TALKED TO HIS FATHER, I'VE
LOOKED HIM IN THE EYE AND I HAVE
EARNED THE KIND OF PERSON
DESMOND MILLS IS.
HE IS A GOOD MAN.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF BAD OFFICERS
OUT THERE, THERE ARE PLENTY OF
GOOD ONES.
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE GOOD, AND
I BELIEVE DESMOND MILLS IS A
GOOD PERSON.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY HE IS A VICTIM
OF THE SYSTEM?
>> I'M SAYING HE COULD BE A
VICTIM OF THE SYSTEM.
THAT JUST BECAUSE HE IS AN
OFFICER, A FORMER OFFICER,
BECAUSE HE IS PART OF THE SYSTEM
THAT I AS A DEFENSE LAWYER SPEND
MY CAREER FIGHTING AGAINST
DOESN'T MEAN THAT NOW THAT HE IS
ON THE OTHER SIDE THAT HE
COULDN'T ALSO BECOME A VICTIM OF
THAT.
SO THAT'S WHY I AND ALL THE
OTHER LAWYERS HERE ARE GOING TO
VIGOROUSLY DEFEND OUR CLIENTS.
>> IS HE REMORSEFUL?
>> YOU KNOW, HE IS REMORSEFUL
THAT HE IS ATTACHED TO ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
THAT HE IS INVOLVED OR CONNECTED
TO THE DEATH OF SOMEBODY WHOSE
LIFE SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN TAKEN.
THAT IS DEVASTATING TO HIM.
>> HE MUST BE REMORSEFUL THAT
THERE IS SOMEONE WHO DIED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> THANK YOU, BLAKE BALIN,
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.